hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i am just checking in on you
um
it is uh it's friday
hey man what kind of [__] example are
you setting for a work ethic if you're
doing your thursday podcast on a friday
man
uh my apologies i um
had a crazy couple of days um
i did quite arguably i think my favorite
show
or venue i've ever done i was out and uh
i keep forgetting what the f because
they both begin with f
i was in forest hills queens
at the original tennis club
i thought i was the one arthur ashe
you know where they had the u.s open
since i've been watching but this was
the original one
um
[Music]
that like they they had the us open
there until 1977
which means uh was probably the jimmy
connors john mcenroe
uh chris evert before she was chris
everett lloyd
um
you know
all of that type of stuff i don't know
but it was um
built in like the 1920s or something
like the outside outside of it was like
made out of stone it reminded me when i
went to the yale bull or harvard stadium
it was just sort of that era of um
stadiums it was incredible
and they had these amazing pictures uh
of the beatles landing there
this is on one of their earlier tours
before they played shea stadium
they did a gig there uh they landed in
this [__] giant awkward looking
helicopter
and they had a picture of jimi hendrix
there on stage
um
[Music]
but it was just a [__] magical place
there was a whole bunch of people there
but it felt like i was in front of i
just thought it was in like a comedy
club
and i uh keith robinson went on first
and absolutely murdered
i had josh adam myers introduced been
playing the um
what do you call it the uh
the trailer for the movie i'm working on
old dads that did great and i came out
at like it was basically dusk and while
i was up there the sun went all the way
down and um
i don't know i'm trying to think of
it was just
out of all the crazy places i performed
in new york city i think that that's
it i'm not it's not even think it is
it's my favorite venue
um so thank you to everybody that came
out there uh
it was it was awesome and it gave me a
big boost of confidence for the uh
fenway gig i have to do
when i go up to boston i'm hanging out
here in new york for a couple more days
um
and then i don't know
work my way up to [__]
boston and do that crazy show
and uh yeah that's what i got going on
man
other than that i've been trying to hit
the [__] ellipticals
know
and uh other than that i don't know what
to tell you i tried to keep up with uh
what's going on with old oh donny boy
the feds are breaking into your
apartment
um
i picked up a new york post because i
always liked that i always liked their
uh
their sports page better than the daily
news and um
[Music]
the front they were you know it's
[__] hilarious this guy's going like
you know
if donald trump runs again he's going to
be president
which i don't really argue that but it's
just like the guy sounded excited by it
just like i honestly
i i have to say since bill clinton i
think this is
this is a like i've this
very rare
human beings out there that just can
repeatedly [__] up and be complete
scumbags and people just don't seem to
see it bill clinton was one donald trump
is another
i just don't [__] understand i just
wish we could somehow get out of this
vortex
of [__] morons
on both sides
um
like i i i don't know
i don't know
at least bill clinton could give his
speech but he just the [__] that the guy
was doing he was just
you know i don't know
i i don't know but like
trump doesn't even sound smart that's
what i i got to give the nod to him as
far as being able to [__] snow people
you know
i guess he said a long time ago
he said only uh
only criminals plead the fifth or
something like that and then they they
get him there and he [__] played the
fifth like 90 times
and i'll tell you this none of it's
going to land none of it will land
with his supporters because no one on
the news channel they watch will bring
it up the same way i listened to people
that supported obama who watched cnn and
they didn't know half the [__] [__]
he was doing
it's really uh they gotta shut down
those two news networks they're keeping
they just won't
they just toe the [__] company line
for a political party it's not [__]
news i know i've been saying this for
[__] ever but it just blows my mind
in fact after my show i had made fun of
both of them and i met somebody this
firefighter guy
and i said something made so he goes oh
you mean cnn i go
no i mean both of them they just sort of
stared at me i go you're not one of
those people who just watches one of
those news networks are you
and he's like no no all the politicians
lie i'm like yes you are you [__]
i get it you know what you know what cnn
and fox news are
they're easy listening for people on
either side you know what i mean
they just kind of say how you see the
world i guess
um oh is that what it is bill did you
[__] break down the news networks you
[__] non-reading [__]
um
i actually uh
i had a really [__] good time um
the night before
my sets um i set out in queens where i
went up
i did a set at the stand
and then i went over and i did a set at
the seller
and
it's i don't know
i i i've been having like this this
thing where i'm i'm
especially in new york because new york
they definitely get like quiet
and uh
i'm sitting there going like all right
so what's going on i've been blaming
them for a while
that they're all [__]
doing that that
stupid
white woke thing
which is basically you're still not
helping out anybody who isn't white but
you're just sort of groaning [__]
and that makes you an ally
and somehow makes people who aren't
white
lives better i don't know i don't really
understand what it is but it's it's you
know it's the typical
sort of uh white liberal thing like i
didn't really do anything but i still
think i'm amazing and i'm fixing the
problem right
um
i have a friend from honduras
um that means i'm a good person
um
so i was up there and it wasn't going
well
i mean granted i was doing this bit on
domestic violence
but the level with which that they
pulled back or anything
uh
i kind of had to admit like dude you're
just
you're just the old comic now
it's kind of what it was i remember when
i was in my 20s in a comic in his 50s
one on stage and he did he wouldn't do
well
down in my 50s now but it was but what's
amazing is it's like inverted
like
when i was in my 20s the 50 year old guy
was like a cornball
and now
and the younger people were just like
and they weren't laughing because what
he was saying was corny now it's gone
the other way
where i feel like they're not laughing
because i'm coming off like a monster
[Laughter]
but it's still the same thing
it's still the uh come on grandpa
you know but it's it's just kind of like
a different [__] vibe when i'm up
there so i just
and i was talking to other older comics
about it and they were like no these
kids today
and i'm like nah dude no that's world
we're old when we were younger we looked
at people our age and they weren't funny
or they would we couldn't relate to them
we're [__] 30 years older than there
you know or whatever um so that was kind
of a fun thing but i was able to um
work out some jokes and i was telling
some stories about growing up in boston
and stuff trying to kind of get those
things
up on their feet because i'd like to do
a few uh
boston stories when i do fenway
is that the lovely nene
no
um
anyways at some point my wife has to
walk in on this podcast
and she hasn't been on the podcast i
feel like in a year
and when i go on the road that's that's
what everybody says to me like i miss
nia being on the podcast
i can't listen to
[__] dumb voice anymore
um
i'm assuming that was my mother-in-law
that just answered me
or a very confident cleaning woman
so i was like nini is that you when i
just hear no
it is me it is you
it is you because i was like that didn't
sound like your mom and i was like is
that a very confident cleaning lady nia
they miss you on the
i podcast you guys too i gotta tell you
something what are we talking about i
don't know we should talk about i gotta
go back over we gotta talk about how
[__] hot you're looking oh my
goodness
nia has been a goddamn
gym rat ugh
huh you've been killing it yeah
i've been trying
you're trying you're doing more than
trying
you look great look at you walking
around here looking good walking around
yeah boosting my ego yeah i went to new
york and i realized that i am an old
comedian oh is that what it took for you
going to new york because i could have
told you that baby
why why did that mean this early in the
morning
no they weren't oh look who it is oh my
goodness hey buddy
look at this hi it's the way in here hey
i thought i had the door closed
you didn't
choo-choo train
can you say hi daddy
he doesn't care um
see i just don't connect with young
people anymore i'm old
what's that
all right i gotta i gotta do the rest of
this and i will i'm gonna be saying the
bad words
hi
how are
doing good
yeah all right well i got to do my
podcast all right
say bye bye
bye-bye let's go find sister come on
boy
yeah all right
yeah okay
i'll see you later
i'll tell you what's funny was staying
in this hotel here
in uh new york right and uh
i realized how you know once again i
just realized how loud my kids are and i
am like really
lenient just over correcting for the
childhood i had
and i've realized i need to have
i got to get a little more respect out
here on the ice because people are just
taking liberties
yeah my kids just look at me i'm like
hey hey hey hey and they just kind of
keep doing they just laugh because they
think i'm [__] around because
i
i don't know i just try to make them
laugh and i've realized that i can't do
that every time because
then when i actually want them to behave
they're just looking at me like oh this
is a bit he's screwing around again and
whatever he tells me to do i do the
opposite then he chases me and then i
get to laugh
and blah blah blah blah
so
whatever i'll i'll
you know
i just don't like yelling at him but i
swear to god sometimes a kid doesn't
hear you until you just yell hey
you know what i'm talking about is how
my kids don't respect me when i tell
them this did you notice that last night
when i was telling them to stop they
just kept going yeah but i you know i
jumped in there and i was like
i know i'm like the good cop you're the
b
yeah you're the you're the bad cop i'm
definitely the bad cop you're not the
bad cop you're the cop that's respected
i'm the rookie
all right i'll see you guys um
anyway i don't i'd rather be a pushover
than be that [__] dad everybody's
afraid of
[Laughter]
i don't know i'll figure it out um
so
anyway oh i didn't get back to the uh
to doing the show uh yeah so i worked
with keith robinson which i haven't done
a road gig with him in [__] forever
he came out and absolutely destroyed
and
[Music]
you know it kind of gave me confidence
that all right this is a great crowd
this is going to be a good time
and uh but just like the history there
is incredible
and
they have this thing
where
they got this little garden thing in the
back and whoever performs there
before you whatever artist was there
leave something in the garden for the
next act and they make like a video and
then you have to do it for the the next
act after that
and uh the guy who played it before me
was ll cool j
which was [__] wild so
he left some something for me it was
actually kind of funny
um
[Music]
so
i mean i'm literally in queens and i'm
playing a place
that llc just played it was just [__]
the whole night
and i'm looking on the wall and seeing a
picture of jimi hendrix playing there
it was [__] uh
it was amazing and i had a bunch of
friends that all came out
um so many people throughout the other
thing too i was just thinking like god
look at all the [__] great people
i've met throughout the years in this
business
um
they're all great people they're all
happy for me
we all had a great hang afterward
um
and then i went into the city the only
thing that was missing from the city was
was a cigar at the end of the night but
it was just it was uh
i don't know it was just too frigging
hot out um but fortunately the heat wave
broke before i i
you know the day before was like 100
degrees and this the night i did it was
only like sort of in like the 80s which
seemed like
like the air conditioning was on after
the [__] 100 degree day but i will
tell you one thing that kind of sucks is
new york
is it's i hope it doesn't go too far the
other way
it definitely is getting its vibe back
again meaning you can get [__] up and
you gotta gotta watch it you know
like i had a nice watch on and i said to
the guy down the stand i go hey i'm
gonna walk over to the cellar am i right
with this watch out there he's like
uh you know i mean you should be all
right and i'm like all right it's going
in my pocket
and then he was telling me uh you know
kind of like from the flatiron building
up that's what you got to watch out for
it's like yeah that's where the prey is
that's all the touristy areas
that people are checking out you know
and looking at their phones and not
paying attention so
oh
i also noticed you know as we came out
of the lincoln tunnel the squeegee guys
are back
like i haven't seen the squeegee guys
since the [__] 1990s
and that was the old hustle where you'd
come out you'd stop at a red light and
they would just walk up and start
washing your windshield whether you
wanted it or not
and then if you didn't give them any
money
they had some piece of something a piece
you know a key or a piece of metal and
as you drove away they just would put it
against your car and scratch your car
uh really you know
sort of like
higher level
capitalism
you know kind of like i mean they're
operating on the same level of like
you know monsanto or like banks
you know like when most santos like you
know
we own all the seeds if our seeds blow
onto your property and land we're going
to sue you for using our seeds
they actually got away with doing that
suing mom and pop [__] farms
and
nothing happened to them
absolutely nothing [__] happened to
them
and way more comedians got in trouble
for telling jokes than than those guys
taking people's farms away and taking
control of the food supply
owning the seeds
and turning
genetically modifying our food supply
and turning so much of our food supply
into actual [__] poison
nothing
what happened to them
nothing i think you can actually if you
say that like on tv you can get sued by
them
like there's something if you actually
say what they're doing they can sue you
[Laughter]
but for some reason they're not a
problem
they're not a [__] problem
um
but anyway i'm back here east coast
i went to an oyster bar
last night oh my god i went to a [__]
oyster bar and
it was the first time in a while that i
wished i was drinking
because they had sam adam's summer rail
on tap i was just like oh my god an ice
cold [__] summer ale
with a half a dozen oysters oh
it's [__] delicious and i had a
little bit of calamari i'm having a
calamari what you haven't
um
it was kind of like the perfect uh
little summertime meal
it's funny i never get oysters during
the winter i always just to me that's
always like a summertime thing
you know i think that goes back to being
uh
just like growing up in massachusetts
well i never used to eat oysters when i
was a kid but like i don't know we would
always seem to end up you know going
down the cape or something in the summer
and you always get fish or some [__]
like that so anyway
um thank you to everybody that came out
to that show
in queens thank you to the crew that
worked there that told me about the
place
um
[Music]
i mean you should have seen the uh i had
like no idea this place even existed i
just thought the whole time the us open
was played where they where they play it
now
and um and flushing right is that
flushing and but i had no idea that they
played it in forest hills first and that
there's the whole forest hills like
tennis club you should have seen that
that building i mean it was
this is incredible i wanted to take a
tour of that it had this really cool
like old school
just look about it slash almost reminded
me of the hotel that was in the shining
which by the way is a gorgeous hotel
it's just that jack nicholson goes in
there and loses his [__] mind if you
can just
get past the movie
it's a beautiful hotel and this seemed
to be like the same era
of architecture and i really really
thought it was [__] gorgeous um
so i don't know who knows if i ever get
to play there again i think i'm going to
come in a day early and maybe take a
tour of the tennis club
and uh take a look a little bit more of
the venue
but um
[Music]
i can't even describe you what it was
like to be on that stage with like
it was dust so the sun was already over
the horizon but all the colors were up
in the sky it was [__] unbelievable
um
and then it was kind of funny with all
of that beauty
i was up there doing [__] jokes
so all right let me get to the
advertising here
the advertising all right we what do we
got here who do we got here oh it's
simply safe everybody
you know here's a question
is there anything that matters more than
the safety of you and your loved ones
of course not
uh well what about the safety of
everybody man so isn't it strange that
many home security companies don't act
that way this is why i use and trust
simply safe home security
the advanced security technology helps
me sleep at night and they always put me
and my family's safety first here's why
i love it with 24 7 professional
monitoring simply safe agents
call you
the moment a threat is detected and
dispatch police or first responders in
an emergency even if you're not home
you know what the [__] just happened
even if you're not home
uh or can't be reached simply safe
monitoring agents truly care about your
well-being and are highly trained to
keep you calm and safe during stressful
situations
uh staying on the line with you until
help arrives simply saves customers
customer first policy make sure that you
you're taken care of with affordable
plans starting at less than a dollar a
day and no long-term contracts or hidden
fees because feeling safe at home
shouldn't break the bank customize the
perfect system for
uh for your home in just a few minutes
at
simplysafe.com go today and claim a free
indoor free indoor security system plus
twenty percent off with interactive
monitoring go to uh simply safe.com
that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash burr
oh and look who it is everybody
one of my favorites here butcher box
everyone
you know this summer and by the way this
summer goes to october now with global
warming uh this summer add some power
players to your grilling lineup with
butcher box butcher box is a
subscription service that delivers high
quality meat and seafood right to your
doorstep choose from a carefully curated
selection of 100 grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken wild caught
atlantis atlantic
wait wild caught seafood you don't know
what it's going to do with more and more
convenience every month butcherbox ships
a curated selection of high quality meat
right to your home free shipping for the
continental u.s no antibiotics or added
hormones packed fresh and shipped frozen
for convenience so you can save time on
your next grocery store trip customize
your own box or go with one of theirs
either way you get exactly what you want
high quality meat delicious 100
grass-fed beef free range organic
chicken pork raised
crate free
wild caught seafood unbeatable value
less than six bucks per meal on average
uh get summer sizzling started with this
special butcher box deal for our
listeners free bacon for life for the
life of your membership they're just
gonna throw some bacon in there every
time you do it every time you're
ordering plus a hundred dollars off sign
up today at butcherbox.com
and use the code bonus 100 to get one
pack of free bacon in every box for uh
for the life of your membership plus 100
off your first order that's
butcherbox.com
and use the code bonus 100
bonus 100 to claim this deal
i'll tell you a claim that i thought was
pretty wild
was the tesla guy whose name escapes me
um
what do i think mosh
nash
musk
elon musk
elon
um elon musk
was saying
that um
he made a claim on a podcast
that the birthing rate was way down with
young people
and that basically the world population
was going to nosedive
and that we were all going to go extinct
rather than it being some big nuclear
war he thought we were just going to go
extinct because everyone was going to
stop having babies and i got to be
honest with you that had to have been
one of the dumbest things i've ever
heard in my life
you know he goes like that's
we're just going to go out with like a
whimper it's like you don't think when
people notice that we're becoming
extinct that people won't then have
babies
maybe did you ever think why they're not
having babies maybe they're not having
babies because they don't want to bring
them into this [__] up world if the
population went down significantly
and we could reverse what the [__] we're
doing to the planet maybe more people
would feel like there's a reason to
bring a life into the world i don't
think that everyone's just just gonna
sit around going well no one's having
babies looks like we're all gonna go
extinct
i have a new theory
okay
smart people who go on podcasts are not
that smart
all right
they're campaigning to be smart
that neil degrasse tyson i mean when is
he when is he looking through a [__]
microscope every time you see the guy
he's [__] on a podcast i'm on a
podcast i went to summer school i'm a
[__]
right and then somebody else oh look at
me
i'm gonna make a [__]
i'm gonna make a [__] spaceship that
goes to mars
you're gonna do it you're gonna sit down
and do it or do you have the ability to
organize and delegate it
where the really smart people that are
making it don't have time to go on a
[__] podcast
all of these [__] doctors and [__]
going on shouldn't they be like what
hey some comedian wants you to go on his
part i'm too busy curing cancer or
trying to
i don't have time to go on and [__]
try to explain what i'm doing to
somebody with a [__] high school
education
[Laughter]
i don't know but i'm dumb maybe like
that's what it is i don't think like
doctors who are on tv are that good at
their job
i don't think [__] uh therapists that
host their own [__] talk show
i don't think they really give a [__]
about the mental health of other people
i just don't i don't think they do
there's just something about it where
it's just like shouldn't you be like
going out there like
i'm not saying all of it like i think
chefs that are on tv are good at what
they do i'm not saying that they're the
best
you know
i mean i'm in this business i know how
that works just because you're on tv
doesn't mean you're the best at what you
do maybe you're the best at the business
or maybe you caught a break
or maybe you know somebody
but um
that whole [__] theory that like
people are just gonna stop having babies
and like that's why we're gonna go to
extinct
it has got to be the dumbest thing
uh i've ever heard in my life because if
that was actually the case then there
really wouldn't be an abortion debate
because there'd be no [__] babies to
abort
right
um
[Music]
now listen i know i don't have a shiny
face of my own car company but i'm just
gonna say i don't think that that's
the smartest theory out there
oh my god shots fired
all right
[Music]
i'm not even upset with elon musk i'm
just
upset with other mouth-breathing morons
like myself that we never question
people like that
well you just kind of sit there going
like or at least i don't i just go well
that guy's really successful he must
know things and then once a while like
well if he's really that successful what
the [__] is he doing
talking to people like me
oh who gives a [__] um
anyway so i'm gonna go up to boston uh
spend like a week out up there and uh
before my gig at fenway and i'm gonna
try to one night
sneak out to fenway to go see
me red sox oh what about the [__]
patriots i actually watched uh they had
a preseason game against the giants
huh
pre-season football what would you do
um
we looked all right man we had some
nice plays on defense and all that you
know it's pre-season i didn't [__]
watch the whole thing
um
[Music]
but i thought we looked uh we looked
pretty solid
it wasn't like an ugly game and uh i
thought on both sides
uh you know i thought the giants had
some good looking players and all of
that so we shall see very excited very
[__] excited the first goddamn
preseason football game
here we go
it's going down again
and uh i'm gonna be on the other side of
my big gigs
and um
i'll be on like when when football
season starts
the fenway gig will be behind me and my
the movie will be blocked
and uh i'll tell you right now
i have one plan and one plan only for
the fall
well actually two plans i'm going to
just be home spending time with my
family and i am watching football i'm
gonna watch the most [__] football
i've watched
since i didn't study in high school when
i was a kid
and i remember i would be watching
football
and my dad would come in to motivate me
to study he would just come in and he
would walk in the room and he would just
scream at this top of his lungs he'd go
study
[Music]
then i'd have to shut up the tv and go
well you know this was pre oprah and dr
phil so like that was what parenting was
back then it was because of that [__]
that now i have so over corrected
that like now my kids my kids treat me
like you know those you know those those
young kids when they have like one of
those [__] super fast motorcycles and
a cop turns on his siren
and they just sort of turn around and
give him the finger and then take off
and make a [__] youtube video
yeah my kids kind of have that element
so i got to get i got to uh i got to
make a couple arrests
um
but uh i'm a big st i'm a big [__]
softy
so um
i am and i kind of sometimes
defer to my wife because i know that
they'll listen to her and i'm just sort
of like
i gotta undo this i've sort of
painted myself as the third child
you know this big bald bearded child
that never moved out so i'm gonna
correct that um
i just gotta figure i gotta figure out
how to do it in a way
that it's not a bunch of screaming and
yelling because that's the only way i
know because that's what i grew up with
so i got to learn how to do like uh uh
i don't know
i just don't want to go above like going
hey hey hey hey hey i don't go above
that
you know
when i was a kid the dads from my era
when they would yell at you you'd pee a
little bit
you're a little
kid anyway that is the podcast once
again i can't thank
uh
people enough for coming out there and
going to that show
it was um it was so much [__] fun it
was so much fun and i really hope
i get to do something like that again
and if i don't i'm so thankful that i
did it it was absolutely [__] awesome
so that's it uh go red sox go patriots
um
and oh my god it's a beautiful day out
it's a beautiful day out i'm going to
put my watch in my pocket and walk
around new york all right everybody
enjoy the music
picked out by andrew themeless the great
andrew themless and we have a bonus half
hour episode of the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast from a podcast a few years ago
i'll see you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
august 11th
jesus [__] christ
i was gonna record this thing sunday
night it's sunday afternoon
you know all of a sudden uh
you know i got invited to a [__] pool
party
now i love the pool
i love the sun i love swimming and all
that but i i don't like going to pool
parties i like going to a pool where
there's a fence and no one can see me
and my pasty body
so i'm gonna go over there and look like
a [__] giant piece of chalk
and a pair of [__] swim shorts but uh
so i figured maybe i'll have a couple of
beers at which point you know old man
like me sitting in the sun drinking some
beers
um this podcast would be an absolute
[__] show
and some of you probably thinking oh you
know that you should have done it dude
dude that would have been epic
make a complete ass of yourself as
opposed to the usual go [__] yourself
get some goddamn friends
you know
get some [__] friends and and watch
them make an ass to themselves not this
guy not this guy not this week
as he points to himself
slapping himself in the chest um
i actually you know a lot of people
don't realize this i could have been an
olympic swimmer
but um i just couldn't get over the
embarrassment i had in the shame
of standing in front of a crowd of
people
with my pasty torso and legs
my giant head but uh you know
and my my little tommy lee leather
underpants that i'm gonna [__] wear
as you're [__] swimming across the
pool but uh i was actually a really good
swimmer
you know i was a really good swimmer
oh i could have been a professional
swimmer is [__] versy still going off
on this [__] classic versey out of
nowhere i minded my own business paul
versi by the way from the versy effect
podcast
um
he just out of nowhere he makes a
classic versi statement which is it's
just it's through the [__] roof
through the stratosphere right out into
the goddamn uh milky way he said no
sport in history will ever be as
psychological
and as mental as golf
he could have just said his uh
psychological was golf he but he was
trying to sound smart so he had and as
mental
nothing could be as sugary
and sugarish
as a sugar cookie
thank you paul so of course i gotta
knock him down
i gotta knock down the statements and
this is what i wrote back i wrote
[__]
uh sissiest sport ever complete waste of
time
and uh i just started going off on it
and he was trying to defend it he goes
well dude you know maybe if you played
it if you played it you've understand
it's like i've played it i caddied for
three summers
you know it's [__] it's exercise for
nerds
that's all it is i'm not saying that the
people at the top [__] level
that some of them
aren't good athletes
okay but i think the average
professional golfer would you want to
see phil mickelson throw a football
you know i'm not maybe he could maybe he
could surprise some people but just
generally speaking look at that guy
that guy is a champion in that sport
look at him
with the [__]
[__] man tits sweat
you know
you ever go down to a [__] golf
course right and you just look at the
average
foursome that's sitting there waiting to
tee off does anybody
anybody even look remotely athletic
they're not you got a stick and you're
hitting a [__] ball that isn't moving
because baseball was too difficult
he's gonna throw it fast and try to get
a pen not even baseball [__] wiffle
ball was too difficult for you so you
went down you bought some three stooges
silly-ass [__] outfit and you go down
there with your cleats
for whatever [__] reason
you know like you're cutting back
against the grain trying to pick up a
couple of extra yards
you're not
you could go down in [__] flip-flops
and you could go play around a [__]
golf
you
know getting a ball it isn't moving
that's a and i'm not saying it's not
[__] difficult who gives a [__]
dude it's so mental
it's so mental you walk up you're
standing over the ball you got all that
time to think about think about what
golf is on the same level as trying to
catch a fly with chopsticks yeah it's
difficult but who gives a [__]
dude i gotta sink this putt
if i don't seek this putt uh if i sink
this putt i'll break a hundred
what if you don't
who gives a [__] nobody cares
yeah dude i shot in 99
nobody cares
cares but other unathletic
[__] or former athletes who had too many
[__] hoagies
and now this is their idea or they're in
a miserable marriage so they go down to
this [__] men's club
they go down there and have a couple of
beers and they stand around right
scratching their balls through the
pocket of their [__] pants
house keys jingling right just psyched
to be out of the house
it's a [__] reason to get away from
your wife
that's all it is okay but enough with
this horseshit
okay and i know i'm not saying that
there aren't people out there you know
that are in great shape that are
professional golfers and all of that i'm
not saying that okay but you look at the
average
champion in golf look at bubba watson
does that guy look like he's ever done
like curls a push-up anything
he just looks how he looks
you know he he's got that you know sort
of sunken in chess with i have a couple
of donuts every once in a while little
[__] flab around the middle
i know i'm gonna get a ton of [__] for
this but i don't care i am so [__]
sick of everybody who plays golf rich
voss is good at golf
from the rich and bonnie my wife hates
me podcast this way i'm hyping
all the podcasts this week i'm [__]
on golf
rich vos
is actually from what i heard not only
good at golf he is an excellent golfer
rich voss
with his little hands
you wouldn't want to see rich voss go
over the middle and try and catch a
football do you think those little hands
could go up and grab it
as some cornerbacks coming in timing it
to knock his [__] head off
he probably stopped slurring if it
happened
but anyways it [__] come in and
hit him right that's not a mental game
that's not a mind [__]
jumping up in the air looking the other
direction trying to catch a flying
object to somebody else who's trained to
knock you out is coming in
give me a [__] break this is what i
love about golf
the average [__] [__] who plays that
game is such
is so horrible
so [__] bad
at that dude go to a golf course it is a
[__]
[__] show
[__] [__] show you go down to play
pick up hockey you go down and play pick
up hoop you see athletes
you see athletic people you go to a golf
course it is a [__] [__] show
looks like one of those fat camp shows
you wait for somebody come stepping out
of the bushes
telling everybody what house they're
gonna live in over the next three months
here's another thing about [__] golf
oh i'm on a tear here here's another
thing about golf i've never seen a
[__] sport where every year they're
trying to and there's so many
non-athletic
uncoordinated [__] playing that
game
that every year they got to try to
improve the equity equipment
to make up for how bad everybody sucks
somehow make the [__] golf ball go
further somehow build a club
to compensate for somebody's [__] man
tits as they come around
do they do they redesign a football
every year so you can throw it farther
[Music]
when are they finally gonna get the
equipment to catch up with how
unathletic the average golfer is and
somebody could actually keep it on the
[__] course
look i'm not saying you know go out have
a couple of beers and smoke some stogies
it's a it's great guy time away from the
ladies or whatever i'm not saying that
but i am so [__] fed up
with everybody trying to justify it
first is a sport
all right let's get into this dumb
argument like what makes a sport a sport
um my thing is if there's not somebody
across from you
trying to beat the living [__] out of
you
um
i'd
or just stop you
i don't i don't think it's a sport and i
don't want to hear golfers yeah the
person trying to stop you is yourself
man that happens in every [__] sport
okay
every [__] sport
okay you want to go up there against
roger clemens at the height of his roid
write it out [__] period and the guy
in front of you just before you went up
went yard on the guy you want to be that
next guy [__] digging into the box
is that guys out there [__] grinding
his teeth
you want to talk about a mind [__]
trying to guess yeah i'm going to guess
which side of my [__] head he's going
to throw at
you telling me standing over that
goddamn ball there's a bunch of other
fat [__] staring at you is difficult
with your space-age design
[__]
driver
these [__] [__] this is when you
know you suck every year you got a new
driver dude i got a new one yeah the
even bigger bertha
oh [__] lazy [__] they can't even
carry their own bags
you know they got some [__]
little [__]
taiwanese kid carrying double bags as
they walk down or they drive around
their little golf carts driving right up
to the ball
and then the mind game starts again give
me a [__] break
all right [__] golf
all right
that's all i'm saying okay this is the
monday morning podcast everybody and uh
you know i say a lot of dumb things and
they go on for a long time that's
basically what happens here uh i want to
thank everybody last week uh that
enjoyed the fact that i called orange
is the new black i called it clam oz
i just think that title's a little long
um
i i've actually tried to watch a couple
episodes
uh of that show and i just
i don't know i just think that
that white girl should be getting the
living [__] kicked out of her a lot more
like she she i've started to watch the
pilot and she just
didn't have enough of a uh i can [__]
handle myself background that you know
every time i drop in i just feel like
she should be painting somebody's
toenails
she never is
she's [__] having arguments with
people
they would just grab her by her [__]
hair and spin her around her head like a
helicopter and throw her in the [__]
corner and then just do unspeakable
things to her she'd be having a horrific
time
she wouldn't have the time to give
monologues
you know i'm sitting on a show i've
barely watched and uh you know which
goes good because i'm [__] on a
sport i've barely played i tried playing
it
i was [__] bored shitless i used to
caddy at this uh
this country club
when i was a youngster i did a
i did it a couple times and there was a
handful of people that were actually
athletic they were actually uh
guys guys social
and they were good
they were good golfers and the rest of
them oh with their stupid [__]
thigh-high argyle horse socks with their
matching [__] i'm selling newspaper
hats
coming out there with their big puffy
and away we go pants
oh those guys were the [__] worst you
didn't make any money
sometimes you try to go out again but
you know half the time you go out with
such a [__] hack
and it had nothing to do with golf just
blaming the sport it's like oh you suck
at golf what sport are you good at
huh accounting
you [__] [__] you'd be better at
counting how many dimples are on that
golf ball then actually once you start
with [__] uh
i don't know what
i don't i don't know i think if you're
gonna play golf you should you should
have to be able to play polo first if
you can handle a horse it'd be hand-eye
coordination to [__] whack that ball
as you're riding on that [__] beast
and his nostrils flaring then i'll
entertain that maybe you're athletic
when you go to walk out on the course
but other than that
with the hazards and the dumb ass
[__] rules
you know
here's another thing too and then
everybody goes out and they [__]
cheat all the time and there's gimmies
and all of that yeah go [__] yourself
[__] all of that
i do like golf courses i like them from
the air it gives planes and helicopters
a place to land
if they ever get in trouble other than
that it's just a complete it's just a
[__] waste of time
um all right bill you've made your
goddamn point
um
[__] what was i just going to talk about
i'd started to go into something else
yeah i don't have any questions for this
week i don't i don't have anything i'm
just trying to [__] i'm trying to energy
my way through this thing
uh let's do a little uh we'll do a
little advertising here okay if you
thought that that was horrific wait do
you hear me try and read out loud
how many we got this week we got uno
single all right
all right back to the podcast did any of
that last part make any sense
um
all right
let's get what what other more moronic
[__] can i talk about
um
well what did i do this week
i went on a long hike this morning
somebody sent me a nice article
about uh the the health benefits of
hiking
which is just like golfing without all
the douche bags
you don't have to keep score everybody
if you just want to go walking just go
just go hike
do you know what's weird
is uh they actually issued a warning out
here for certain parks that uh that
women should not be hiking alone because
evidently there's one or two perverts
that are riding by on bicycles
grabbing ass and titties as they go by
and uh
i know that that's wrong but like
what what do you
what do you think like what kind of a
[__] game plan
i mean we all like ass and titties right
why wouldn't you just walk up and say
hello
try an opening line
say how beautiful her eyes are like
i hated going to school but if i could
go to school and become a psychologist
and just or a cop who when they finally
catch this hunk of [__]
um who's kidding who this damaged child
that now has become an adult
you know they can afford a bicycle
um
like i don't understand
are they fat
no because that wouldn't work cause
they're on a bike i'm thinking like
they just i bet the person's small
if i'm gonna try to break down what i
think this person looks like here i'm
gonna do a little police work all right
i think the dude is small
because he's worried that after he
sexually assaults the woman by grabbing
a boob or a butt
uh
she's she has the chance of beating the
[__] out of him so i think he's a
smaller fella
um
just coming right down the [__] hill
riding down the hill with his dick
standing up
that's one of the scariest things i
think i could ever think of
i wonder if he yells as he comes by
he just reaches out and grabs her ass
look at that titties i mean that's
[__] horrible
what is now when they catch this guy and
he goes to jail anybody who goes to jail
for uh for you know
you know any uh pedophiles or rapists
anything sexually
[__] up they have a rough time so like
what would they do with him
you know what would be the uh the
punishment
i mean he doesn't deserve an ass raping
for that does he
because if he deserves an ass rape and
then what what the [__] does the ass
raper deserve it's a very slippery slope
it's almost like you know doing your
stand-up act you can't start with your
closing bit you got nowhere to go
you can't be on 10. this guy deserves
like what i'm gonna ask ladies like what
do you think this guy deserves
god knows with them it's never enough
right it's never enough
like when they suspended stephen a smith
after he said i'm gonna keep talking
about that because it was such [__]
when he said you shouldn't hit a woman
right
um and they still suspended them they
went and they cut to this woman right
this lady and she's like he got
suspended like three days or some [__]
cost him like [__] half a million
dollars
you know
and uh because he said you should never
hit a woman
and then he had the audacity to say
let's try to examine the problem from
360 degrees you know
um he gets suspended like three days and
this [__] woman comes on tv and she
goes i don't think it's enough
i don't think it's enough i so wanted to
be on tv and just be like is it ever
enough with you [__]
see that's right that's exactly it you
called us all [__] no i'm not you
[__] [__] i'm calling you a [__] all
right that's all it's a joke
lighten the [__] up
dude i swear to god you could go out
the average woman you could go if you
went out and you bought her a [__]
mercedes-benz
four-door
hard top or whatever you know what
they'd say
how come you didn't get the convertible
not saying all of them but enough of
them
i guess we do [__] too like you didn't
even notice i got my hair cut
oh i thought you got a new shirt i mean
we're morons i guess
i'm trying to be more empathetic as i
get older but uh it's never enough
it's like they're treating the guy like
he hit somebody
ah
i don't know i guess i've exhaust
exhausted that topic what are you doing
you have an hour-long podcast and you
don't have any [__] emails
andrew was supposed to send me these
[__]
things but he's on a hiking excursion
which i understand because i would not
be [__] sending emails either plus
i'm doing it way early so i'm just gonna
have to sit here and just [__] deal
with this goddamn silence
um
what am i gonna bring to the pool party
other than my lack of pigment
i don't want to [__] drink in the sun
you know
hey i'm doing another one of those uh
what is it the uh the god damn comedy
jam i'm doing another one of those
and uh
i'm not gonna tell you the song that i'm
playing but i have to go down to the
[__] drum
whatever the [__] it is i'm not gonna
give anybody
i wish it was a private one i know
professional drum shop i'll go down
there
on vine
i gotta get a uh
i gotta get a cowbell
i just had to pause and wait for
somebody to yell more cowbell
for the umpteen thousand time like it's
still funny
um
i gotta get the cowbell you know you you
actually hit it with the bass drum i'm
gonna put it right next to the [__]
hi-hat i'm gonna try to do a note for
note
cover of this [__] song and uh this
is my new like
this is this is my golf this is how the
[__] i have to get out of the goddamn
house i probably shouldn't have gone off
like that hard on golf right
is that right oh before i before i get
off totally off the subject here uh
thank you to everybody who helped uh
benny greb
uh raise some money for his uh dvd
project um drum video uh thing
that he's trying to put together i'm the
worst at promoting [__] but i i
appreciate it um
all right and back to the uh
the golf [__] i probably shouldn't have
been that difficult you know people go
out they have a good time
you know
i don't [__] know
i'm just already anticipating the amount
of [__] people are gonna give me for
that
um anyways you know what let's talk
about you know this is something i
haven't talked about in a minute because
i took off the [__] summer
um
yeah that's what i did it took off this
summer and then my whole [__]
downstairs out went to [__]
do you know some weirdo check emailed me
she goes stop referring it to your
downstairs like she was getting
something weird sexually out of that
like that was my issue and i need to
stop saying that it's just like
it's like okay yeah i guess that's on me
that's not on you
i'm talking about my house and i say the
downstairs and you somehow are thinking
about my dick and balls your weirdo
um
that's the type of [__] people send you
all right here's here's what i got going
on
coming up um very quickly by the way
august 21st
i'm at the jiffy lube live
[__] extravaganza center arena
whatever the hell it is in bristow
virginia
doing the comedy oddball tour
um on august 22nd i'm at jones beach joe
that's not even a [__] long island
accent
long island um nikon at jones beach
theater
oddball comedy tour these are all
oddball comedy tours slashing slash pay
for bill's basement tour
i'm doing the dte energy music theater
uh on august 29th
in clarkston
michigan august 30th i'm at the first
niagara pavilion
august 31st uh whatever let me just [__]
the pavilion [__] august 31st i'm in
tinely park illinois the hell is that
september 14th i'm in uh irvine
california
and on um
november 14th i'm at the west palm beach
improv because i'm going to that
hurricanes uh
i almost said samoan hurricane seminal
game uh the next day
and the day before the
on the 13th i'm going to that
dolphins bills game which is going to be
the [__]
um
so anyways that's what the [__] i got
going on and for those of you if i'm
coming back to a a um
city or an area and you saw me last year
i all i got i got a brand new [__]
i got a brand new uh like 40 minutes
okay i take my act
it's done that hour is gone it's [__]
dead to me
it's [__] dead to me and uh i'm
coming with all new [__]
all right
so there you go
just cause i'm going out because i have
to pay for my [__] house
does not mean that i'm gonna [__] you
over i am coming with new material
new material it will be and it's one of
the great lineups of all time a couple
of those shows
uh well let's click on let's see what we
got here listen to this [__] here
all right i clicked on it my internet's
working really slowly lately i don't
know what that means
hey did you hear like like google and
all these other [__] guys they're
trying to buy up the whole internet and
then you're gonna have to [__] pay
them a vig every month or they're gonna
make your website super slow
uh
you [__] they're not even gonna tell me
who the [__] on these
you can't do that to people
how could you do that to people all
right let's see in bristow virginia
lineup
all right here we go amy
schumer
hannibal burris dave attell brody
stevens jeff ross
uh chris hadwick
and uh brent morin
look at that look at that lineup
um one of them i think uh what is it i
think it's the uh the jones beach one
that's the other one i look up before i
like this whole podcast goes into just a
boring oh that's the oh jesus oh
jesus listen to this lineup for jones
beach david tell louis ck
sarah silverman chris
hardwick
brody stevens jeff ross hannibal burris
and myself
all right that show should be called go
[__] yourself
oh
oh billy boy's gonna go on early on that
one
um all right back to the uh back to the
podcast here um
all right you know who gives a [__] i'm
just i'm gonna i'm gonna just start
reading just random
uh emails that i i got off my uh off my
web my webitode there
uh hey bill hi how are you huge fan
i haven't read any of these things i
just
i sort of glanced at him yeah you made
me land some time
um i recently saw a small interview in
which you said buying a house unless you
are buying it straight up with money you
have meaning without a loan i guess is a
stupid move
could you please elaborate because i
think you're out of your mind that's not
what i said and also that was part of a
longer interview and they took a
15-minute conversation and made it a
minute and a half
um this is what he says let me tell you
my situation
my wife and i
have been renting a condo for a thousand
dollars a month not including utilities
uh three bedrooms garage great
neighborhood all that jazz the american
dream everything that the american dream
is all about after a year of renting
total spent 12 grand i decided i'm gonna
buy a place in the same neighborhood
uh i gave a tenth out i gave 10 down
payment oh jesus
oh jesus
oh god dude
you're gonna have that dick in your ass
forever
um and my mortgage is now 870 a month
taxes included while my rent was a
thousand for the same place like the one
i just bought
now the rent money i am never gonna see
again
um that's 12 000 gone forever in only
one year which i obviously don't regret
spending since it was a necessity
however let's say i pay for my house for
10 years
i would have paid roughly a hundred
thousand dollars off for it what
sure i will get raped on taxes interest
rate from the bank yada yada then i go
sell it even if the price for the house
didn't go up at all i'm going to see
some of that money back sure not all of
it but even if it's half of it that's
still way smarter than renting for 10
years and seeing none of it
uh
blah blah blah you're gonna present the
usual argument all right dude
you're paying a thousand dollars a month
to rent because
you don't have like a 500 grand hanging
over your head and you can [__] leave
whenever you want
and if anything goes wrong on the condo
somebody else has to fix it
so you're sitting there acting like you
got this condo and it's 8.70 a month
and that is um
a month and that is like your only
expenses it isn't
you're easily paying at least a thousand
bucks let's and you want to talk about
throwing money away if you just make the
uh monthly payment that 870 like 860 of
that is right in the toilet that just
goes to the bank
you don't own 870 dollars more your
house you own like nine dollars more
um
they slowly bleed you for 30 [__]
years and what i was basically saying is
that
buying a house
that you can't afford
is a stupid move
because all you're doing is staying in
it paying interest on it while it
increases in value the only person
making money when you go to sell it is
going to be the bank and the real estate
agent those are the only two people
and um i don't understand that whole
[__] thing like say you bought at the
right time and then the [__] thing
shoots through the roof right your house
doubles in price
and then you sell it and then you've
doubled your money but now you need a
place to live
so you have to go by go back into this
market where everything's doubled so
it's just a lateral [__] move all the
money you made you've not got to put
into this other house unless you somehow
downgrade your life which why would you
want to do that
um
the only way to make money i think
really in a house
is uh if you can afford it and you can
pay it off
quickly
if you can pay it off quickly then as
the house increases in value
it's increasing in value for you because
what happens i feel over the years when
you're paying the interest the interest
is always slightly ahead of how much the
house is appreciating in value and
that's when you didn't get completely
[__] over if you bought at the at the
height of a bubble like so many other
people
um
you're upside down in your house and you
could stay in it for 30 [__] years
and you still might it still might not
be worth as much i mean i don't
i don't know i don't really understand
what you're trying to ask me it's just
like
i guess yeah you
after 10 years you could sell your house
and you would get some money but you're
not adding them you're not adding this
money
properly
like
let's say okay you were throwing
12 grand a month uh 12 grand a year
into the toilet you said but you had the
luxury of not having a half a million
dollars in debt hanging over your
head you also have the luxury of you can
basically give a month's notice and
[__] leave
okay um you don't have to go through the
trying to sell the [__] house and
oh my god is this the uh you know the
wrong time to be selling it and blah
blah blah and oh [__] the
water main broke i have to pay for that
you don't have to pay for any 12 grand
bing bang boom it's all done condo thing
people come by trim the hedges mow the
lawn you don't have to pay for any of
that [__] [__] 12 grand a year
done
it's a beautiful [__] thing now
owning a house is a beautiful [__]
thing if you buy a house that you can
afford
okay if you can just kick the [__] out
of the principal but if you're gonna go
in there and just pay 8.70 a month
as that house appreciates in value it's
appreciating in value for the bank not
for you
i hate to tell you that sir but that's
basically it okay so let's say now
you're throwing 870
okay
seven hundred dollars
a year
okay
to
we'll just say roughly we'll say 8 500 a
year in interest over 10 years you're
talking about you know it starts to go
down and the more you've paid in
interest that first 10 years is mostly
interest so you're going to give them
like 75 000 you're going to throw into
the [__] toilet
all right plus all the expenses all the
taxes all the [__]
of owning a [__] house all the [__]
that i'm going through right now
um
it makes paying a thousand dollars a
month and not owning way better
way better the fact that you can just
[__] leave whenever you want to and
if there's a problem you can call
somebody up and be like yeah dude you
know
you need to fix this
i will not stand for this me and my
thousand dollars a [__] month so
um you're paying way more than 870 bucks
a month is all i'm saying
and i'm not saying like that's great
that you actually
what you should do
is are you taking that extra 130 a month
that you're saving and throwing that at
least throw that at your principal
anything
to somehow start sawing away at the
chains around your [__] ankles
um because it is a [__] over
do this sir
do this whatever your [__] principle
is
okay multiply your monthly payment times
12 and then multiply it times 30 and
it's going to be roughly two and a half
two and a half times what the [__] uh
your loan was
okay so if your loan was safe for 500
grand you're gonna pay them back
probably anywhere from 1.2 million
dollars
to 1.5 depending on what your [__]
interest rate was
okay and i don't think in 30 years
you're gonna get a million and a half
dollars for that [__] thing and let's
say you do forget it you paid all the
taxes and all the [__] had to put a
new roof and fix the [__] driveway
and the electrical and the pipes and the
water damage and the [__] god knows
what else
the termites and all the [__] that
happened i mean you'll like if you break
even you [__] crushed it that's all
i'm saying
all right
now i might be a dick i might be raining
on your [__] parade there but uh
that's why i feel like
if you can buy a house that you can just
pay off even if it's a [__] if you
can just pay it off in five years you're
better to keep renting and buy a house
in another [__] state you don't want
to live in just buy that thing
get people in there paying the [__]
mortgage and then you you pay
pay down the [__] principal
you better to do that and then sell that
[__] thing and use the equity in that
to then get into a [__] house where
you live where you want to live
and uh
try to kick the [__] out of the
principal but uh that whole thing
getting into a house and all you're
asking is what is the monthly payment
gonna be you are gonna get [__] in the
ass
seven ways to sunday as they say that's
what i was trying to say but they cut
out a ton of what i was uh
what i was talking about sir
okay so there you are was that boring
well it kind of bored me too
um let's let's steer into the boring and
let's do a little more advertising oh
jesus this podcast started fast and it's
dying a slow
slow [__] death um dude that's just
like golf you [__] kill it on the
front now shut up
ugh with your slacks
all right here we go
um
dollar shave club everybody uh ever
wonder why razors are so expensive
big shave companies are charging you for
uh for ridiculous shave tech you don't
need
first vibrating handles then flashing
lights now pivot ball flex heads what
next the mpv uh p3 players over there
enough is enough join dollar shave club
for a few bucks a month dollar shave
club delivers the world's best razors
right to your door
i think dollar shave club better uh
blades are better than the big shave
companies uh
for a fraction of the price it's so easy
go to dollarshaveclub.com pick one of
their razors that uh they start at three
three dollars a month come on come on
you tight pricks uh you don't break the
bank you don't have to rest uh resort to
cheap disposables to save cash dollar
shave club is amazing every month they
ship you
um automatically whatever you want they
bring it right to your house it's for a
fraction of the cost this should have
been done years ago finally somebody
picked up the ball and got it right
you'll never have to buy blades again
you don't have to squeeze shaves out of
some dull dirty old razor scraping up
your face you get a sh you get to shave
with a fresh blade every week this is
absolutely mandatory for anybody that
wants a great shave you deserve better
than a dullo blade no more ridiculous
shaving technology make the smarter
choice
join dollarshaveclub.com
dollarshave shaveclub.com
all right and finally everybody hulu
plus
you've probably tried hulu on your
computer hulu plus is so much more with
hulu plus you can watch shows on your
schedule hulu plus has all your favorite
shows like cosmos a space-time odyssey
bob's burgers or undateable starring
crystalia
and watch every episode of shows like
south park the cosby show or doctor who
and many more hulu plus works on your
computer smartphone roku apple tv xbox
pretty much anywhere that uh streaming
pretty much any streaming device you
already own god i'm brutal this week you
should be blocking off a day just a
binge with hulu plus you're in total
control to stream these and thousands
more as much as you want wherever you
want
if you saw the giant bullet points they
made to try to help me through this and
i'm still screwing it up
hula plus is awesome despite my read
okay also get exclusive access to stream
the criterion collection movies and hulu
plus has all of them all movies and kids
shows are ad-free too for only 7.99 a
month get your shows anytime anywhere
but right now i'm offering my listeners
a two-week free trial when you go to
huluplus.com
bill bravo
india lima lima that's a whole extra
week free please make sure you use
huluplus.com
bills so you get an extended free trial
and so they know that we sent you it
helps us keep the lights on and gives
you a better deal one more time for the
extended for that extended free trial
huluplus.com
bill
all right there you go there you go
um hey bill i need some advice about
what a girl did to me what this [__]
broad did to me over here
uh you see this person says okay so i
started talking to this girl and we hung
out
you know what we had some fun
she's beautiful
has a great personality
fyi
what pisses me off is the way she led me
on by telling me how lucky she was to
have met me and all this other [__]
so i started to fall for this broad over
there
uh she's the first girl that i ever fell
in love with
uh this is way
oh wait this is she's the first girl
that i ever felt this
this way before
now is that me and him she's the first
girl that i ever felt this way before no
that's him and it's both our first year
in college
so out of [__] nowhere
she tells me that she's got a [__]
boyfriend which got me [__] mad the
guy's dropping the f-bomb i'm believing
it here so my question is why did she
lead me on just to drop me for some
[__]
uh is this guy mexican for some other
[__] uh i'm stupid because i still
like her
set me straight bill and tell me what
you would do in that situation and if
that ever happened to you before thanks
um
oh jesus did it ever happened oh
absolutely i've been both of those
people
i've been the douche and i've been you
um
all right let's see here why did she do
that because she's young
you're both young let her go man she
could she could have done
what could have happened to you
is so much worse
okay
she could have uh
i don't know
you could have married her had a couple
of kids with her and then then you find
out that she wants to be with somebody
else that could happen you got off easy
you're young you're in the prime of your
[__] life
you know
you're in your first year of college
dude you're a number one draft pick you
got your whole life ahead of you
you know
i mean like like
the level of [__] ass that you could
be banging right now just out of sh she
the sheer potential that your life still
has
and what's great about it your age you
don't really have to prove anything all
you have to do is be majoring in
something that sounds like there's a
bunch of cash at the end of the rainbow
you tell a [__] couple jokes you're
in there
okay so whatever you know look
here's one way to look at it you know
you got let's just say that she isn't
just young and immature because that's
what that sounds like
um
that's that's best case scenario she
might be an absolute psycho
at which point you totally got off easy
because uh she's out of your life
so what i would do is uh
what i always say this is what you want
to do next time you see you're gonna
look great because you're gonna go to
the gym you're gonna get [__] jacked
all right you're gonna get in the best
shape of your [__] life and you're
gonna start hitting on ass
[__] two three levels above her and
one of them's gonna say yes
the law of averages
then someday you'll run into her and be
like would you look at that [__]
broken down hunk of [__] that i actually
was worried about
you know now look at me
and i'm not saying this new girl isn't
gonna crush you too
that's that was bad for me to say that
i'm gonna get you to the point where you
can't trust people but uh you know so
it's a
it's one of the uh
one of the
growing pains a final finding whoever
the [__] you're supposed to be with i
guess i don't know
i don't know i'm sorry she did that to
you it sucks um i have had that happen
to me i was uh
how can i tell this story without
getting anybody in trouble
um it was one of my earlier
relationships uh this woman was a
musician she was a lot older than i was
and she was in a band uh
and there was another dude in the band
who was married to another chick that
was in the band
and um
you know she quit her day job and
started spending a lot of time over this
guy's house writing i'm doing the air
quotes right now writing
working on music writing
uh the dude's wife was getting upset
was saying i don't like you spending all
this time with this other woman
he said it's innocent we're just
writing
we're over here writing and um
my girl came home to me and said she was
upset that this other broad would ever
think that oh my god how the [__]
you know uh that she would ever do
something like that she's like i would
never do something like that i love the
guy but as a friend
i'm just over there writing
long story short
me and this woman break up
i start a comedy career and about a year
and a half later i'm doing a show
and uh
who comes up to who comes up to me at
the end of the show
the wife of the guy that my old
girlfriend was writing with
and i say
good to see you she's like yeah i can't
believe you're doing comedy that's
awesome oh yeah it's great to see and
all that type of [__] and i was like hey
where's so-and-so
and she goes oh she's with your girl
your ex-girlfriend now you know and i
was just like jesus christ and uh
i realized that
they probably were not writing when we
were dating
[Laughter]
and i would love to tell you that i only
had one of those stories but i i had a
number of those i had like uh
i had like three women that i know of
that did that you know
and then i [__] around two in
relationships so i mean what are you
gonna do well a little gibson you take
some what are you gonna do
it happens
it happens people human beings they [__]
up they make mistakes
you know but you got off easy
you got it easy jesus christ i told you
that [__] story didn't i i know i
told this one before that time
oh my god
that was right when i knew i was gonna
be a comic i was i went to one of her
shows
and they were in this band i can't say
the name of the band
all right i'm not trying to get anybody
in trouble but they made these
sweatshirts for the band that they were
selling after the show and they were all
white
and they said the name of the band in
like this miami vice pastel
okay
and it's the early 90s so the pastel
look is [__] at least i mean that was
mid 80s this is early 90s
so
they're gonna sell these after the show
and the woman i was dating
said she wanted me to wear the
sweatshirt during their [__] show
and i was everything in me was screaming
going i don't want to do this i don't
want to do this but for some reason i
was at that age i was i was afraid of
having a confrontation
um
and i i [__] did it anyways i sat in
the crowd at their [__] show they had
an outdoor show during the day and i sat
there with a sweatshirt on
written in pastel with the name of their
band
oh i you know
that's unfucking believe why didn't i
just say that was so much of my adult
life
was learning to just say no i don't want
to do this
um
you know because i i had like more of a
uh you know
my childhood upbringing was hey sit down
and shut the [__] up you know
when that is like the communication that
is going on as you're growing up like
you will find yourself sitting at a show
wearing
a sweatshirt with pastel writing on it
and
not knowing that you have all the power
to be like i don't want to do this and
take it off
um or just not put it on
you know but i'm glad i didn't say no
because the only way i knew how to say
no then was i really would have hurt her
i couldn't just say listen
um
i'm not wearing it it's too effeminate
okay do you have any guy ones
you know do you got a black one in there
with like it's written in
something other than pink and aqua
[__] blue
all right i was getting hope if i if i
really loved her i would have wouldn't
have had a problem if i was really
comfortable with who i was i would have
[__] i would have cut the sleeves off
i would have tied it off right just
[__] skip right down the aisle
professing my love but i didn't love her
so i don't give a [__] that she banged
that guy in the band good for her good
on you
lady from my life [__] 25 [__]
years ago
oh jesus that was an old jesus one right
there that was another yet uh the
zillionth oh jesus moment in my life
i'll let me tell you he had a rough one
out there you know
um
anyways football season is coming up
i'm so [__] excited man i'm actually
more excited for the uh
i'm more excited for college football i
can't [__] wait oh let me tell you i
can't [__] wait you know and i don't
have any dates
i don't have that many dates this uh
this fall i'm just in town building up
my new hour because i'm not gonna go out
on the road
and [__] people over and do the same
[__] i did the last time and then i just
[__] myself over
that's not the way to do it
um
and i'm also uh
i got a little project and i'm writing
that you guys might see the light of day
at some point
you know
oh [__] freckles oh freckles you know
you hang around hollywood long enough
they might give you something
i'll tell you be careful what you wish
for
um
what did i want to talk about oh by the
way if you if you enjoy this podcast if
you enjoy the ramblings of a man sitting
in his boxers in the middle of a sunday
afternoon about ready to go to a pool
party
um
and you want to donate but you don't
really just want to give me money you
want to get something out of it just go
to uh billboard.com you click on the
podcast page and you go over to the
amazon uh
banner and you click on that
and go buy yourself something it doesn't
cost you any extra money and amazon goes
hey here's a couple of bucks for sending
them our way we appreciate it isn't that
nice
isn't that lovely isn't that how the
world work
um
i actually last week said underrated and
i said it was amazon's [__] itunes
thing that they have and these [__] i
just want the music
and now they're trying to set up this
cloud thing for me it's just like
like welcome to amazon music here's a
few tips to get you started please don't
exit the app while we load your library
and then they got this little circle
thing with that [__] cloud
switch between your cloud and your
computer libraries go [__] yourself
why do you have to have my music this is
what i don't like about all these
[__]
this computer [__]
i just can't walk in and buy something
and leave they got they got to take a
piece of me they got to figure out
what's he into what's he doing man
they're like some psycho chick you bang
her one [__] time and she's gotta
[__]
at least get a t-shirt out of it you
know
what why does my music have to live
on your site i hate that [__] word
they're just they're trying to hang on
to you to just keep getting more [__]
money they're like they're like leeches
i'm just gonna go back to buying records
i swear to god
you know the only thing i do like about
you know the ipod and the iphone is that
you can listen to all that music while
you [__] walk around are you in the
car that's tremendous that you can
actually do that
but um
other than that the [__] trade-off
these [__] [__]
i hate one night like i even go into
stores now and i'm just like yeah i'm
just paying cash i'm just paying cash
and they still scan something
they'll be scanning oh you want to make
sure you get the discount just like let
me get this straight you just went out
of your way to to have your company make
less money
and they're okay with that there's no
[__] way that's all that is that is
somehow trying to collect data at the
very least the fact that i paid cash
they're at least doing some sort of
moving like uh inventory of their [__]
but if i use like what i hate is they go
hey you got a little safety save [__]
card and i go no i don't and i don't
want you don't scan anything
i'll swipe my card and then they [__]
s they s they scan something i'm like
what the [__] why did you just do that
oh i tried to tell you my you put me in
the system
i just want to get my [__] toothpaste
and leave
what do you then watch me from a [__]
satellite
he switched brands of toothpaste what
does that mean
how can we get more money out of them
these [__] [__]
i swear to god they've done that to me
at at the pharmacy like two times
and it's as as you can see it's driving
me up the [__] wall
the only thing that drives me even more
up the wall is the people that don't
that are so [__] dumb they don't care
i mean wha why do i give a [__] where
the dead [__] figure it's like
they're making money off of you
they're taking your private information
and then what they do with that is they
then sell it they share it with other
businesses as they build a file on you
shouldn't your private information
or information on you
okay maybe because you bought it in the
store it's not private
but like shouldn't you get a cut of that
they're setting up this behind the music
thing where they're gonna own the rights
to everything that you [__] do and
what
should you get a cut of like hey
you know we we we shared this
information or what kind of toothpaste
uh you like with [__] arm and hammer
over here and they gave us you know
eight bucks for that good well give me
two bucks
because if i didn't walk into your
[__] store you got you got nothing to
sell unless i walk into your store
i'm bringing something of value and i
would like my [__] two dollars at
least pay me
it's the principle of the thing ah jesus
look at that i made it i made it coming
up on an hour [__] tremendous um
all right speaking of downloads
i was talking last week about that
aretha franklin i want to try to
download her early albums like in
like
complete albums
because uh
you know because she's aretha and all
they do is just play her [__]
her greatest hits
you know what i mean they don't have
[__] like this you know
this one listen to this [__]
[Music]
come on where was that song they always
play respect
you better think
they never play this song you know
i want to be free
to fly away
come on and sing
to the world
she's the [__]
and i was thinking you know itunes
didn't have it i can go over to amazon
this is the more mom-and-pop place how
[__] dumb am i
you know i just realize i'm bitching
about this thing and i actually have a
banner of them on my site
[Music]
i'm in bed with these horse
um oh jesus you know what that is that's
hypocritical behavior or am i just that
stupid
we'll let you decide well that's the
podcast for this week everybody i'm
really excited about football college
football coming up
um
baseball playoffs i always playoffs i
like those you know
october
uh the red sox have completely [__] to
bed i guess they let everybody go and
you know what's weird that's when i get
into him that's when i love him i'm
sitting there rooting for him against
the angels every time i looked up they
were [__] losing you know
but padroi is still getting up there
swinging for the fences
yeah what are you gonna do
um any football predictions bill
no no i have no idea what's going on i
don't watch the draft i don't play
fantasy football i don't collect
football cards anymore i am completely
out of the [__] loop i have no idea
what's gonna happen i think the uh
i think the jets got a little stronger i
think we got a little weaker i think
buffalo got a little stronger i think
you know we're we're kind of in our swan
song of tom brady he's in the final
third of his career he has the ability
to win another super bowl but i just
don't know if we're going to be able to
get him the right players in time
uh that's what i'm kind of feeling but
hey the end of it he won three of them
you know can't get mad about that and
he's also one of the legends right up
there with larry bobby teddy ball game
bill russell and all those [__]
um and okay that's it that's the podcast
for this week ladies and gentlemen
gentlemen and ladies
okay let's be fair to the women here
okay
they want equal rights so every once in
a while you have to go second gentlemen
and ladies i am off to a [__] pool
party
uh i hope i'm not gonna be sunburned
um uh it's just the worst i'm gonna feel
like the boy in the bubble i'll be the
guy like under the umbrella with my
knees up in my chest
it doesn't make any sense
that my skin is this [__] light and
that sun does what it does
to my skin i've been to ireland i've
been there it's sunny
i don't get it
i guess scandinavia when you get out in
there but i don't have any scandinavian
blood
the [__] did that come from
scotland guess it rains all the time
i don't know i think i'm just weird all
right everybody that's the podcast this
week go [__] yourselves have a wonderful
week and i will talk to you next monday
you